[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
ya está conmigo en el estudio jorge
hurtado jorge yo me sigo lamentando de
no tener vicio medio bitcoin porque
alcanzó nivel récord no 60 mil dólares
ya está al alza así es bueno el valor
del bitcoin continúa en ascenso y esto
es interesante porque es impulsado por
el lanzamiento del primer fondo cotizado
o edf por sus siglas en inglés en esa
cripto moneda en la bolsa de eeuu sólo
este martes raúl subió 2.6 por ciento en
las operaciones asiáticas y rondar a los
62 mil seiscientos dólares y es probable
que en las próximas horas supere el
récord histórico que alcanzó en abril
pasado de 64 mil 800 dólares el
entusiasmo se debe a que el gestor de
activos browser pretende iniciar el
fondo en la bolsa de valores de nueva
york este mismo martes según fuentes de
bloomberg el valor del cripto activo ha
crecido de forma acelerada en los
últimos meses de 2021 luego de una
estrepitosa caída a mediados de año por
las regulaciones en china que llevaron
su precio hasta los 30 mil dólares para
el bitcoin y para efe en general este es
un paso histórico raúl el director
ejecutivo de project michael shapiro
comparó el lanzamiento de este etf
vinculado al mundo cripto con el
lanzamiento del primer jefe de acciones
en 1993 o de lanzamiento en 2002 dlt efe
de bonos iniciales las cripto maneras en
industrias de casi
2,5 billones de dólares de las cuales el
bitcoin es el más grande con un valor
total de casi 12 billones por su parte
el mercado estadounidense de efe creció
a más de 54 millones de dólares el fondo
se va a centrar en los futuros
relacionados con el bit con en un
mercado que es supervisado por los
reguladores de eeuu jorge cambiamos
ahora de tema porque la escasez de
energía ya se convirtió en un problema
global como ya también veníamos hablando
en nuestro programa durante estas
semanas y afecta a varias regiones bueno
la unión europea china e inclusive aquí
en américa brasil y eeuu la presión
sobre los mercados del gas natural el
petróleo y otros combustibles mantienen
la economía mundial funcionando pero a
su vez genera facturas de luz más altas
productos más caros y una creciente
preocupación sobre cómo europa y china
los mayores consumidores van a hacer
frente a esta situación en europa por
ejemplo euro europa importa el 90 por
ciento de sus suministros de gas los
precios han subido ahí cinco veces más
desde inicios de este año los analistas
argumentan que son varios elementos los
que alimentaron esta crisis vinculada a
la escasez de gas dicen que la demanda
aumentó cuando la economía se ha
recuperado de la pandemia y que un
fuerte invierno agoto las reservas rusia
que es el principal proveedor de gas
para europa retuvo los suministros de
verano para tener reservas locales para
el invierno la demanda de electricidad
de china también volvió con fuerza y hay
limitantes para exportar gas desde eeuu
por eso o por esto más bien el precio de
la energía va en aumento en eeuu las
autoridades ya advirtieron que los
precios de la calefacción podrían subir
hasta un 54% españa francia italia y
grecia anunciaron medidas económicas
para tratar de dar ayuda a los hogares
más pobres core hablemos de otro tema de
actualidad y le pregunto cómo ha
evolucionado la economía en mianmar
luego del golpe estaba el pasado primero
de febrero y las autoridades buscan
sobre todo equilibrar o estabilizar la
moneda la moneda de magia que está
afectada por esta inestabilidad política
en septiembre la moneda perdió más del
60% de su valor luego de meses de
protestas vuelta y estancamiento
económico provocado por el caos político
que dejó este golpe la inflación se
disparó al 6,51 por ciento desde que los
militares tomaron el poder y las
reservas extranjeras en esa nación son
de 11 billones de que acceso es más o
menos unos 6 mil 40 millones de dólares
la caída del valor de la moneda ha
influido en el aumento del costo de los
alimentos y combustibles que afecta a la
población sólo este año raúl el banco
mundial estima que se economía va a
contraerse un 18% mejores indicadores
como están las bolsas bueno asia
cerraron mixto por la leve caída de ella
carta después de que el banco central de
indonesia mantuviera los tipos de
interés sin cambios en europa operan
actualmente al alza por las ganancias en
las acciones de minería y tecnología que
ayudaron a compensar las pérdidas en el
sueco eriksson y para finalizar que nos
trae como cifra del día jorge has visto
esta serie del calamar
bien dos días bueno 21 poco
21.4 millones de dólares costó la
producción del juego del calamar la que
es la popular serie de netflix eso es
casi
24 millones de dólares por episodio y
aunque su costo fue relativamente bajo
generó 891 millones de dólares en valor
de impacto esta es una métrica que
utilizan netflix para evaluar el
rendimiento la serie soy la más vista de
toda la historia en esa plataforma
jugaremos la mente de jorge gracias por
toda la información de economía vamos
ahora a ver nuestro reportaje vale